Speaker 1: Many people wrote in
to me saying, David, did you see
the assassination attempt of the Argentinean
vice president, Cristina Kirchner, which was
caught on video? David, you're Argentinean.
Please tell us what you think about this issue.
Well, I have to tell you, and this is going
to anger a lot of people, including even some
people in my friends and family. The entire thing
stinks to high heaven. That's my honest view. So
let me tell you what allegedly happened, and then
we're going to kind of dig into it in more detail.
BBC News reports Cristina Kirchner gunned James
during bid to kill Argentina vice president.
Argentina's vice president has narrowly avoided
assassination after a gunman's weapon jammed as
he aimed at her. Footage shows the moment that
Cristina found herself face to face with the
loaded weapon. The former president was outside
her home, surrounded by a mob of supporters
who back her in her fight against corruption
charges. Police said the gunman, identified as
a 35 year old Brazilian man, had been taken into
custody. They're trying to establish motive. The
president, Alberto Fernandez, revealed the gun
was loaded with five bullets but failed to fire
when triggered. And indeed, this was caught on
video. And you see this it really is incredible
video where you see Christina walking around and
all of a sudden a handgun is right in her face.
And then she looks Cristina looks down at the
floor and it's not clear she knows what happened.
And then all of these security people, of which
she has dozens and dozens around her all the time,
run over and then this guy is taken
into custody. I have to be really,
really honest with you guys. To me, this
stinks to high heaven. And I know many people
don't necessarily follow Argentinean politics
and what's going on there. Cristina is a
criminally corrupt individual and there are major
charges against her. There is a corruption trial
where a prosecutor is seeking a 12 year sentence
against her and a lifelong ban from the office
from running from holding public office. She
says she's the victim of political persecution,
prosecution. Both terms kind of apply here and
it is really not looking good for her. Now,
you might remember there was another prosecutor,
Alberto Nisman, who also was moving forward very,
very strongly against her with corruption
and other charges. And just before
he was going to be presenting evidence in a court
of law, he was found dead of a supposed suicide.
Now, having studied that issue seriously
for many years, I don't believe that
Nisman killed himself. It doesn't make any sense
when you understand the full scope of the story.
And so now you have another prosecutor
who is bringing serious charges,
serious evidence. The other day, the president of
Argentina said, I hope this guy doesn't also kill
himself in a completely dystopian, almost Putin
like statement. And then now all of a sudden,
despite the fact that Cristina has dozens of
security people, some poor Brazilian guy is able
to go right up to her and point a gun right at her
head. And there were five bullets in the gun and
oops, the gun jammed and Christina's absolutely
fine. And all of a sudden, all of the attention
is on this rather than the very serious crimes of
which Cristina is accused. So call me skeptical.
Yes, call me skeptical. Now, there are people
and by the way, I know people will write in,
my Argentinean viewers will say, Geraldo, you're
a mockery guy. You're a right winger. No, no, no,
no, no. I think that Mauricio Macri, basically
Argentinean. Trump was also horrible and did a
few good things, did a few good things. Okay. But
not a guy that I supported. The the context here
is very different. Just because I think Christine
is corrupt doesn't mean I'm a right winger,
doesn't mean I like Macri or whatever. But it,
it all absolutely stinks to me, so. Oh, and,
but what I was getting to was many of the people
who love Cristina are reacting to people saying
what I'm saying by saying, Oh, you sick supporter
of violence, you want her assassinated? No,
no, I don't want anybody assassinated. I want
everybody alive and well and able to face whatever
charges are brought against them in the judicial
system. Okay. So, no, I'm not advocating for
anyone's assassination. So that's my view on this.
And to the extent that people in the audience
might be following it, let me know what you think
real quick. September 19th. We are doing it's 919
and we are doing a 19 themed membership special.
It's too good to even reveal what it is.
So if you've been thinking, Oh, I don't
know, maybe I'll get the membership,
maybe I'll get access to that bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: If you've been thinking about that and
you've been waiting for the right opportunity,
I suggest the right opportunity is September
19th, where we will be emailing everybody on
our mailing list about this great membership
special. If you want to be notified,
just get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.